this is also what we haven't seen yet  and I think it's going to take a decade  or maybe even two to see is the power of  podcasters I think it's going to be  going in a complete different direction  the next decade or two where a lot of  these guys you think people are getting  numbers right now we haven't even seen  people having 100 million subscriber  channels yet wait till people have 100  million subscriber Channel and they're  doing a clip every clip they're doing  they're getting 14 million views 18  million views you you lose the game so  this race of 10 to 20 years it's it's a  it's going to be a very media is going  to be a very very different game the  next 10 to 20 years